so i have a two by two matrix here and
we could view it
as having two column vectors so the
first column
can define this vector three one which
i've depicted in blue here
and then that second column you can view
it as
telling us that we have another vector 1
2 which i have depicted in this pink
color
now an interesting interpretation of the
determinant
of this 2 by 2 matrix is that the
absolute value of the determinant
is the area of the parallelogram defined
by these two vectors what i mean by the
parallelogram defined by these two
vectors
well imagine taking this bottom vector
and shifting it
so its tail is at the head of this pink
vector
so it would look like this hand draw it
so it would look something like that
and then if you were to take this pink
vector and copy it and shift it
up and to the right so its tail is at
the head of the original blue vector
it's going to look something like that
and so you can see you can use that
technique to take
any two vectors in the coordinate plane
and they will define a parallelogram
and it turns out that the area of this
parallelogram is going to be
equal to the absolute value of the
determinant of this matrix here so
what's that going to be
well we know how to figure out the
determinant it is 3 times 2 which is 6
minus 1 times 1 which is 1 which
is equal to 5. and of course the
absolute value of 5
is 5. now that's pretty cool in and of
itself we figured out
one interpretation of a determinant
which will be useful as we
build up our understanding of matrices
but another interpretation
is to say all right what if a is a
transformation matrix and i'm just
rewriting it
so we know what a transformation matrix
does it tells us what to do
with the unit vectors so to speak so for
example
i have this vector right over here which
is the vector
1 0 we know that a transformation matrix
says all right take that 1
0 vector and turn it into the 3 1 vector
so turn that into
that right over there and we know we
have the other
or another unit vector let's call this
this right over here is the
zero one vector goes zero in the x
direction one
in the y direction and the
transformation matrix says hey turn that
into the
1 2 vector but then you could think
about it it's also
not just transforming the individual
vectors
it's also scaling up the area defined by
the vectors
so the area defined by these two
original we could say
unit vectors we can see it's one by one
it's that area
right over there so this transformation
is taking us from an area of one
to an area five it's scaling it up by a
factor of five
now that's reasonably interesting just
for this one
unit square but because of that it'll
actually scale up the area
of any figure let's say you had a figure
like this so this type of
oval circle thing it has some area
if you apply this transformation matrix
it will look something like this
i'm just approximating it it would look
something
like that so this will tell us that this
bigger blob
has five times the area of this original
blue blob because the bigger blob
is the image once we've transformed the
smaller blob
by this transformation matrix
so if i were to tell you that the area
of
this smaller circle is let's say 0.6
but then we were to apply the
transformation and somewhere to ask you
what is the area of this bigger blob
which is the image of the smaller
circle after the transformation well you
would take
0.6 multiplied by the absolute value of
the determinant of the transformation
matrix
you'd multiply it by 5 so 0.6
times 5 would be 3 square units
and a hint at the reason why this works
is is that any region on the coordinate
plane can be represented
as a series of squares and then if you
apply the transformation you're really
just transforming
each of those individual squares so the
scaling up of the area would be the same
scale you do to any one of those smaller
squares